DAN RUSSELL: Good afternoon,
everybody.
Welcome to this episode
of Authors at Google.
I'm Dan Russell.
And I'm the host for our guest
today, Jeff Johnson.
And I know Jeff because back in
the mid '80s we were both
at an institution
known a Xerox.
I was at PARC and Jeff was at
Office Information Systems.
That means, he got to work on
the Xerox Star which if you go
down to the Computer History
Museum, you can find.
It was a fantastic,
groundbreaking system that
commercialized a lot of the
ideas that later showed up in
things like, oh, the
Macintosh, and
other kinds of systems.
You've actually used--
may or may not know it-- you've
actually used a lot of
the work that Jeff has
done over the years.
He's also not just a user
experience person, but he
programs in Java, Mesa-- does
anybody remember Mesa--
C++, even things like APL.
So he's a remarkable guy who's
probably best known for his
bloopers series of books.
And you can come and check out
some of them up here later.
The one I first saw was "GUI
Bloopers." But then there were
"Web Bloopers," and "Web
Bloopers 2.0." Which are sort
of catalogs of all the mistakes
that we make and we
should learn from.
So these are really interesting
books if you are
all interested in user
experience design.
So Jeff's talk is a part of the
growing user experience
education effort that's
being led by the
infrastructure team.
And we're going to be having
more tech talks in this series
so please stay tuned.
If you like this one, we're
going to have more.
And you'll enjoy your
participation in that.
Also notice that we're
coordinating--
well Cindy, who's sitting back
over there with her hand up is
coordinating a workshop
and tutorial here--
well somewhere here
at Google--
on February 7 where Jeff and
Austin Henderson will be
talking about returning the
notion of the conceptual
design models.
That will be open for
registration on GLearn I guess
in a week or so,
real soon now.
And there's space
for 50 Googlers.
So sign up soon if
you like that.
Jeff's book will be available
in the back, $15, cash or
credit card.
So if you like his talk, you're
going to love his book.
So please join me in welcoming
Jeff Johnson to talk to us
about how to design with
minds in mind.
Jeff.
JEFF JOHNSON: Thank you.
So thanks to Cindy Yepez and
Robin Jeffries for arranging
this talk, and to Dan
for hosting it.
How many of you design
user interfaces?
Good number.
Goo.
Well those of you who do that,
how many of you ever looked at
or seen user interface design
guidelines like the ones I'm
displaying now?
These were developed by and
written, published by Ben
Shneiderman in 1987.
And all subsequent issues of his
book up to now remain much
more or less the same.
How many of you have seen
guidelines like these when
you're designing user
interfaces?
OK so now we'll look at some
similar guidelines that were
published by Nielson
and Molich.
They were intending these to be
used for website design and
website evaluation.
Now I'm not going to go through
the guidelines in
detail, because that's not
the subject of this talk.
But I will point out that
there's similarity between
these guidelines and those that
have been put forward by
Ben Shneiderman.
So the question is, did Nielson
and Molich plagiarize
the earlier guidelines
by Ben Schneiderman?
And then subsequently, did
Debbie Stone and her
colleagues--
in the book that they published
in 2005, has a
similar set of guidelines--
did they plagiarize?
What was the reason that these
guidelines were much the same
in these different
publications?
Well I'm going to argue that the
reason is not plagiarism.
The reason is that user
interface guidelines
are based on us.
They're based on how we work.
That's where those guidelines
come from.
Now I used to be in the
guidelines business, or
actually anti guidelines.
So when I wrote "GUI Bloopers"
and its sequels, I was sort of
in the, don't do this.
Do this instead.
But I didn't really explain
it in those books why.
And I found that user interface
designers typically
are not satisfied with just
being told, thou shalt.
Or even, thou shalt not.
They like to know
why thou shalt.
Why shalt thou?
And so the other problem is that
it's difficult to follow
those guidelines if
you're a designer.
Let's go back and look
at some of those
guidelines for a second.
First step to goal
should be clear.
What does that mean?
That's pretty vague.
First step is fairly clear.
But what does it mean for the
first step should be clear?
What is clear?
What makes something clear?
When is something not clear?
So the point is that guidelines
are not rote
recipes that you can
just follow without
any background knowledge.
Applying user interface
guidelines effectively
requires understanding their
scientific basis.
Understanding where the rules
came from so that you can
balance the trade offs
that occur when there
are competing rules.
If somebody says to
you, make it fast.
Make it high-res.
Well maybe you can't do
both of those things.
So you have to choose or
you have to find some
kind of trade off.
It helps to understand where the
rules came from in order
to be able to apply them.
So I wrote this book that
was about that.
That's basically about how the
human perceptual cognitive
processor works, or I should
say processors--
I'll get to that later.
How it works and where do these
design rules come from,
that's what the book "Designing
With the Mind in
Min" is about.
Books have chapters.
So some of the chapters
deal with perception.
I'm listing here on this slide
the perception chapters.
And then there are some
chapters on cognition.
I'm not going to talk about
everything that's in the book.
It takes about two days to give
a tutorial that covers
the entire book.
And we have an hour.
So I'm just going to cover a few
of the facts about human
perception and cognition
in this talk, and
show you some examples.
So the first one is that we
perceive what we expect.
What you are perceiving
right now is not
what is really here.
What you're perceiving
right now is biased
heavily by many things.
The main things that I'm going
to talk about right that bias
your perception are the past,
the present, and the future.
The past is your experience.
The present is the current
context, everything else
that's going on right now
in this situation.
And the future is your goals.
What are you planning to do?
What are you trying to do?
All of those things heavily
bias your perception.
Your perception is almost in no
way reflective of what is
actually out there
in the world.
I'll put it that strongly.
So I'm going to show
you some examples.
How many of you are
familiar with the
art of Jackson Pollock?
So here's Jackson Pollock.
He's landed a great gig.
He gets money for throwing
paint onto canvases,
splattering paint on canvases.
What a great gig, I wish I could
get a gig like that.
OK so I'm going to show you
a Jackson Pollock image, a
Jackson Pollock painting.
Everyone see the splatter
painting?
OK so now I'm going to show
you something else.
I'm going to show you
a dog sniffing the
ground next to a tree.
It's a Dalmatian.
Does everyone see
the Dalmatian?
So there's the dog.
There's the tree.
He's sniffing the ground.
His tail's in the air, hind
feet, front feet.
This is actually a famous image
by a guy named RC James.
I could basically tell you what
you were going to see by
showing you pictures of Jackson
Pollock painting and
things like that.
And then telling you
you were going to
see a splatter painting.
So basically the past influenced
your perception.
Now I've told you it was
a Dalmatian, and then I
showed it to you.
And how many see the Dalmatian
by the way?
It's about everyone.
And now the interesting thing
is, if you ever see this
picture again you'll never not
see the Dalmatian, ever again.
So what does this have to do
with computer system design?
Well let's assume that we have
a multi-page dialogue box,
otherwise known as a wizard.
So it's a multi-step
dialogue box.
It doesn't matter what's
on the pages.
So if you watch someone using a
wizard and a usability test,
what you'll see is fairly
predictable.
So basically they read what's
on page one, whatever it is.
They fill out what whatever
fields are there.
And they click Next.
And it goes to page two.
And so then they read on
whatever's on page two.
And they fill out any fields.
And they click Next and
it goes to page three.
And then they fill it out, and
then they go to page four.
And then they click
the Back button.
And it goes back
to page three.
And they say, why did it do
that, I clicked Next?
And you say, no I was watching
you, you clicked Back.
And they say, no I didn't
I clicked Next.
And you say no, I was paying
attention to what you were
doing and you clicked
the Back button.
And then you take
the page four.
And they, oh, the back button is
in the opposite place than
it was on all the
other buttons.
Of course they didn't notice
that because they weren't
paying attention to the position
of the buttons.
They were paying attention to
their task of whatever it was,
buying an airline ticket,
reserving a hotel room,
whatever it was.
So their perception was based on
their past experience, not
only with this dialog box, pages
one, two, and three, but
with all previous wizards that
they've used before.
So that biased their
perception.
Now let's talk about current
context biasing perception.
Here we have two symbols.
They're identical.
They're the same symbol.
But depending on what context I
put them in, your eyes will
perceive them, or more
accurately your brain, will
perceive them as an H that's
kind of crooked or an A that's
open at the top,
automatically.
Or let's move away from the
domain of letters to the
domain of graphics.
So we have a line here.
This is called the Muller-Lyer
Illusion.
So we can take that line
and duplicate it.
So now there are two of them,
exactly the same line.
And then we put these on them
and now even though you know
that it's the same line, your
eye sees the top one as longer
than the bottom one.
And you can't actually
stop yourself from
seeing it that way.
So this is context affecting
perception.
Now here's the interesting thing
is that the brain is
multi modal.
As you know you have
many senses.
And the context can
be cross model.
The content influence, the
biasing of perception by
sensory input can be from other
sensory modalities.
So there's a famous effect
called the McGurk effect,
which I'm just now going
to show you.
Which is that based on what
you're looking at-- by the
way, let me ask you this
question, how many
of you can lip read?
Well in fact you all can lip
read as you're about to see.
Now I want you to listen to
what this man is saying.
And I have to give credit to
some unidentified blogger on
YouTube who put this
video on YouTube.
It's probably the best
demonstration of this that
I've seen and it's
unidentified.
So I don't know who to credit.
But I want you to watch
this video.
MALE SPEAKER: Bah bah.
Bah bah.
JEFF JOHNSON: He's saying
the same sound.
MALE SPEAKER: Bah bah.
Bah bah.
JEFF JOHNSON: You hear a
different sound depending on
which guy you look at all.
MALE SPEAKER: Bah bah.
Bah bah.
JEFF JOHNSON: That's an example
of your hearing being
biased by what you're seeing.
You can actually all lip read
and you didn't know it.
And as I said earlier, the
future also biases your
perception, your goals, what
you're intending to do.
People, especially adults, tend
not to notice things that
are unrelated to their goals.
Our mind is designed to notice
the things that are related to
what we're trying to do.
So I'm going to show you the
contents of a toolbox.
And I want you to tell me if
there are scissors in the
toolbox, OK?
Were there scissors?
OK.
Was there a wrench?
Some people saw the wrench.
So there is a game you
can play in your
house if you have guests.
I'll describe it quickly.
Which is if you're sitting in
your living room and your
guests are with you in the
living room, you can send them
into the kitchen.
And probably in your kitchen
somewhere you have a drawer
that has random kitchen
stuff in it.
I know I do.
And you can tell them,
go to that drawer.
It's the third one down from
the left next to the
refrigerator.
And get me the turkey baster.
And bring it back.
And then when they come back,
you say, was there a meat
thermometer in the drawer?
And they will have no idea.
Most adults will have no idea.
A six-year-old actually will
probably have a pretty good
idea of all the other stuff in
the drawer if you can get them
to come back in the first place
because of all the cool
stuff that was in the drawer.
But that's because their brain
isn't quite as goal directed
as the adult's is.
So in terms of website design
for example, if I put you on
the home page of the
University of
Canterbury's website.
And I say I want you to find me
somewhere in this website a
map of the campus that shows
the computer science
department and where it is, your
behavior at that point is
very predictable.
What will happen is, your eyes
will start moving randomly
around the screen
very quickly.
Your eyes move 10 times a
second, tenths of a second per
saccadic eye movement.
Your eyes are moving very
quickly all the time in almost
random motion.
But because I gave you the goal
of looking for a map of
the computer science department
on this website,
your eyes will spend a lot of
time over these places, where
it says departments, the word
departments, the campus map.
And maybe also your eyes will
zero in on the search box
because you're starting to
think about maybe typing
something in there and looking
for search box.
But you will probably exit the
page without ever noticing
that you've been randomly
selected to win $100.
Because nobody asked you
to look for that.
Now I'm going to talk
about color vision.
The human color vision system
is very unlike a camera.
A digital camera is depicted
by this graph on the right.
So on the right essentially what
we have is the spectrum
across the bottom
of the graph.
And what we have is,
in a camera--
we have on the plate at the
back of the camera.
We have a bunch of photo
sensitive unit.
Cells you can call them.
And a pixel is made
up of three cells.
One that you would call
a red sensor.
One you call a green sensor.
And one you call
a blue sensor.
The red sensors are sensitive
to light in a certain range.
The green sensors are sensitive
to light in a
certain range.
And the blue have
a certain range.
And notice those ranges overlap
a little bit and the
amplitudes or the maximum
sensitivity of the three kinds
of sensors are approximately
the same.
It's designed that way.
That isn't how the human eye
works at all in terms of color
perception.
The human eye has--
well let me ask you
this question.
How many of you remember from
high school or college that we
have rods and cones and the
cones are for our color
perception and the rods are for
black and white and sort
of brightness?
How many of you remember that?
Well you can sort
of forget it.
Because it's only partly true.
The rods really we don't use
them very much in modern
industrial society.
They were designed for
use when we lived
mostly in the dark.
And let me ask you this, how
long ago was it that people
lived their lives mostly
in the dark
unless it was daytime?
About 100 years ago.
It was only about
100 years ago.
So our ancestors, and all of
the animal ancestors before
them, basically had these rods
which were designed to help us
see in situations
of low light.
But in the modern world in which
we live, where it's lit
most of the time even at
night, our rods are
completely maxed out.
So they're screaming all the
time providing very much
little information.
You rods in your head right
now, in your eyes, are
probably just going, ahhhh, like
that and not giving you
much useful information.
So let's forget about them for
the rest of this talk.
Basically what happens
is you've got cones.
They're called red, green,
and blue by biologists.
But that's actually sort
of misleading.
Because the red sensors are
sensitive over almost the
entire range of what we
call visible light.
The green ones are also
sensitive over almost the
entire range, but not as
sensitive to light overall as
the red ones.
And the blue ones are hardly
sensitive to light at all, for
those people who
have blue ones.
Some people have
defective ones.
So the human visual system
does not work the
way a camera works.
A camera visual system
essentially works by addition.
Every pixel is the sum of the
red, green, and blue response
to the light that's hitting
that pixel.
That's the RGB value that
you're familiar with.
The human visual system
can't work that way.
Because how could it work that
way if the sensitivity ranges
of the three kinds of cones
overlap so much?
It could not work by addition.
So it doesn't.
It works by subtraction.
So there are basically three
channels of information coming
from your cones to your head.
One of them is yellow minus
screen, or green minus yellow.
I can't remember
exactly which.
And the other one
is blue minus--
sorry one is red minus
green and the other
one's blue minus yellow.
And then there's a third one,
which is such a complicated
function of additions and
subtractions that produces
brightness from the cones.
So the cones are producing the
brightness information as well
as the color information.
And they are doing it by
subtraction not addition.
Which makes our visual system
almost insensitive to absolute
brightness levels.
So if I take this illustration
which a college classmate of
mine Edward Adelson produced.
And you see the checkerboard.
Can you see the there are
certain squares in the
checkerboard marked a and b?
Can you see that?
What if I were to tell you that
the a square is the same
shade of gray as the b square?
It's the same shade.
So I'll demonstrate that to you
by taking a piece out of
each one with Photoshop
and putting it over
there on the right.
Now but you still don't
believe me.
You think I cheated.
So I'll take the image.
Blow it up.
And then I'll cover up that.
Cover up that piece, that piece,
that piece, that piece,
that piece, and that piece.
So the human eye is really not
designed for detecting
absolute brightness levels.
It's designed for detecting
differences, edges, changes.
That's what it's designed for.
So what that means is that
humans have trouble
discriminating certain
kinds of color pairs.
So for example if two colors are
both pale, people may not
be able to see the difference
between them depending on
exactly how their
cones function.
And also by the way on the kind
of display that they're
looking at.
Like for example I'm
looking at this on
my Macintosh screen.
And you're looking at it on
a projection display.
And then there's also
these monitors here.
And all of those can influence
how you see the two colors and
whether you tell the difference
between them.
So all you color designers out
there, you graphic designers
who think you're in total
control of the color that your
users are seeing, forget it.
You are not in control.
Their eyes are in control.
And the displays that they're
using are in control.
Similarly, people have trouble
discriminating color patches
that are small.
So if you have two color patches
that are very small
and the colors are close to each
other people aren't going
to be able to tell
the difference.
But if you make the same color
patches larger, it'll be
easier for people to
tell the difference
between those two colors.
So what does that say if you're
making a graph and
you're putting the legend over
on the right or underneath the
graph with little dots that show
you the different colors
of the different lines?
Make those legend dots big.
Don't make them little
tiny squares.
Because people won't
be able see the
difference between them.
Comparing colors is also
easier when patches are
together than when they're
separated, especially if eye
movement is involved.
Because if I'm eye movement is
involved in the comparison,
then memory is involved
in the comparison.
So if I move these two together
it's easier to tell
that they're different than
if they're separated.
So if we look at ITN.net,
which is a website for
ordering airplane tickets and
hotel reservations, and we see
that they have said that they're
showing me what step
of their process they're on.
And they're trying to show me
that they're on step one.
But they're using pale yellow
to mark the steps.
So we're on step one.
Now we're on step two.
Can you see that change?
Some of you can probably
see it and some of
you probably can't.
And it also will depend on the
display that you're using.
Some people have color
blindness.
So about 8% of males and about
a 0.5% of females have some
kind of color vision
deficiency.
Now color blindness does not
mean people can't see colors.
The term color blindness
is misleading.
What color blindness means is
that there are certain pairs
of colors that people cannot
just tell apart.
So for example a friend of mine
who's red green color
blind cannot tell
the difference
between these two lines.
To him they look the same.
Now just out of curiosity is
there anyone in this room for
whom these two lines
look the same?
We're looking for the
8% number here.
OK so there's one.
Now think about that.
Think about that for a second.
If you create a graph
in which different--
let's say it's stock values over
time, Apple, Google, and
various other stocks--
and the lines cross.
It's not just that the person
is not going to be able to
tell which one is which.
Wherever they cross they won't
even know which one goes on
from that point.
So it's really a serious
issue for people
who are color blind.
So you really have
to be careful.
My friend who is colorblind also
can't tell the difference
between these two lines.
Now he's classified as
red green colorblind.
But this line I would
call blue.
The other one I would
call purple.
But he still can't tell
the difference
between these two lines.
And this one, one is black
or dark brown and the
other one is red.
He can't tell the difference
between either
of these two pairs.
So you really have
to be careful.
I don't want you to go out of
this room and say, Jeff
Johnson says don't use color
in our user interfaces.
Because that would
be pretty boring.
What I'm saying is don't rely
solely on color to convey
information.
If you're conveying information
with color, use
other cues that are redundant
with that.
So for example, I would really
improve ITN.net's display by
in addition to using a brighter,
more saturated
yellow to mark the current step,
I would also bold the
box and the word
and the number.
Now how they improved it without
actually asking me.
They never consulted with
me unfortunately.
But that's fine.
They improved it this way,
by making the step--
sort of inverting its color and
putting the sort of blue
area around it.
Now that's just as good.
So basically people are going
to be able to, regardless of
what their color vision problem
is or what kind of
monitor they're using, they're
going to be able to tell what
step they're on.
Now peripheral vision.
Human peripheral vision
is very bad.
It's very poor.
There's an error message
on this screen.
Does everyone see it?
It's right there.
This is an actual screen, a
login screen, of a web app
that a client company
of mine created.
This is an actual screen.
And that's where the error
messages were displayed.
And so in usability testing
here's what we saw.
User types in ID.
They type in pin number.
And in some cases we gave them
incorrect IDs and pin numbers,
so that they would get
an error message.
And what happens is the user
types the ID, the pin number.
And they hit login.
And the screen re-displays.
And the fields are blank.
And the user goes, what?
Why did the screen re-display?
Why are the fields blank?
I don't get it.
I must have hit cancel.
So they fill in the ID again,
which is still wrong and the
pin number or one of
the two is wrong.
And the screen re-displays
again.
And they go, huh?
Am I nuts?
That time I was paying
attention.
That time I know I hit
the login button.
What is going on here?
Oh, why didn't I see that
error message before?
Here's why.
There are actually three reasons
why they didn't see
that error message before.
And they all combined to make
peripheral vision of humans,
and actually almost all
mammals, horrible.
Reason number one is that what
we're seeing now in this graph
is the distribution of rods and
cones across the retina.
Now as I said earlier,
we can pretty much
forget about the rods.
But you can see that there's
non in the middle.
There are no rods
in the middle.
And then a little bit away
from the middle, they are
pretty dense.
And then the density falls off
as you get to the periphery.
Cones on the other hand, are
very dense in the middle.
That is to say there are 158,000
cone cells per square
millimeter in your fovea,
in the center
of your visual field.
Now to give you an idea how big
a visual field is I want
everyone to hold their arm
out at arm's length and
hold your thumb up.
And look at your thumbnail.
Look directly at
your thumbnail.
Your thumbnail spans the size of
your fovea on your retina.
And the rest is periphery.
Everything else is periphery.
So your thumbnail is 1%.
We've heard a lot recently
in the news about
the 99% and the 1%.
Here's another one.
The 1% of your visual field in
the middle when you're looking
directly at something.
The 1% is the fovea.
And that's high-res.
Everything else is low-res.
And there are three reasons why
everything else is low-res.
Reason one is the density of the
cone cells in the middle
is 158,000 per square
millimeter.
And in the periphery, not very
far from the center, it falls
off to 9,000 per square
millimeter.
Now 9,000 is a lot per
square millimeter,
but it's not 158,000.
That make sense?
That's reason one, high density
pixels in the middle,
low density pixels
everywhere else.
The other reason is that in your
retina, every cone cell
in the fovea sends a fiber out
to the optic nerve that goes
back to your visual cortex.
Every nerve cell in the
fovea sends one fiber.
The optic nerve that leaves
your eye that goes back to
your visual cortex is a cable
with millions of fibers in it.
Every cell in the middle of
your visual field, in that
middle 1% sends a fiber out.
In the periphery, which is
everything else on the other
99% of your retina, three or
four cone cells combine to
send one fiber.
So what does that mean in
computer geek speak?
It means the data coming from
the middle is uncompressed.
And it's compressed with data
loss everywhere else.
So you can think of it
as you got a TIFF in
that middle 1%, high-res.
And you've got a JPEG everywhere
else, low-res JPEG.
And reason number three is that
when you get back to the
visual cortex at the back of the
brain, which is called the
occipital cortex,
there's a map.
The occipital cortex forms
a map of the retina.
But half of that map is devoted
to processing from the
1% fovea area and the other
half is for the rest.
So think about it that way.
Your brain, your eyes--
by the way biologists consider
your eyes to be part of your
brain, but anyway.
Your visual system is set
up unlike a camera in
almost every way.
Because a camera has its pixels
distributed evenly
across its plate.
The human eye has high
resolution in the middle and
low resolution almost
everywhere else.
So let me tell you, the
resolution of the human eye at
the fovea is approximately 300
dots per inch at arm's length.
If I print something on your
thumbnail at 300 dots per
inch, if you have normal vision,
you can see the dots.
What is the resolution of your
visual field at the edge?
Guesses?
How many dots per inch?
It's measured in
dots per foot.
The answer is three.
The effective size of a pixel
at the edge of your visual
field is approximately
the size of a
cabbage at arm's length.
Now everyone is rolling their
eyes and looking around the
room and saying I see everything
in high-res.
Your eyes move three
times a second.
You can't control it.
It takes a tenth of a second
for an eye movement.
And by the way your vision
shuts off during those
saccadic eye movements.
But you don't see the
world in blinks.
Here's an interesting exercise
you can do later.
Which is, stand in front
of a mirror.
Put your face right
on the mirror.
And look at your left eye.
Then look at your right eye.
Then look at your left eye.
You will never see
your eyes move.
But somebody standing there
watching you will see your
eyes move back and forth.
But you will not.
What you will see is, you're
looking at your left eye.
You're looking at right eye with
no time in the middle.
That's because during saccadic
eye movements
the brain shuts down.
But it also is takes those two
pieces of video and stitches
them together in time.
So you never notice the little
black intervals.
So if we look at this website
of Airborne.com, this login
page, one of the things we see
is that there's an error
message here in red over
on the upper left
underneath the title.
But it turns out people also
have trouble seeing that error
message, because they pressed
a login button.
Well now we know why.
Because if we show what the
eye sees when a person has
clicked the login button before
they move their eye at
all, before the eye moves.
This is what they see.
This is what the eye sees at the
moment the login button is
clicked, before the eye
moves anywhere else.
And remember eye movement
is somewhat random.
It is actually guided by goals
and many other things.
But one of the things that can
make it move somewhere is
movement or change.
And the problem is there was
some red stuff in the upper
left before and now there's
still some red stuff.
So the eye doesn't really
see a change.
So there's no reason for the
eye to actually move to the
upper left.
Therefore it's not going to
see that error message.
Or at least there's a
probability that the eye will
not see that error message.
I think that the probability
that the eye will see this
error message is higher than it
was in that previous one.
But it's still not guaranteed.
And of course this is why you
get in usability test--
programmers in the back room
watching the usability test
and saying, what's
wrong with you?
Don't you see it?
It's right there
on the screen.
No because they're human.
They don't see it.
Because their eye was not
given a reason to
move in that direction.
So in terms of user interface
design, how do you make sure
that error messages
can be seen, or
information can be seen?
Well put it where users
are looking if
you can predict that.
Put it near the error
if there's an error.
Use red for errors.
Or use an error symbol, like
one of these error symbols.
Now here's an example of that.
So for example at AOL.com, if
you sign up basically for
their service there's
a long form.
I haven't shown you
the whole form.
You go down to fill out all
the stuff on the form.
And then you clicked done.
And if you've got a password
that they don't like for some
reason, they will
send you back.
They will scroll you back to
this place on the page.
They put an error
symbol there.
They tell you how good
your password was.
They put an error message,
which is in red.
They highlight the
field you're in.
And they put the cursor there.
You are not going
to miss that.
Now there is some heavy
artillery that you can use to
make sure people are going to
see error messages or other
kinds of information.
But you have to use
it carefully.
You can pop up things and
error dialog boxes in
front of the user.
Some people hate that.
Other people turn off pop
ups in their browser.
So there's certain situations
in which that's not a useful
thing to do.
There's audio you can beep.
But of course imagine a room
like this where everyone's got
their computer and they're
all beeping.
Whose is beeping?
I can't tell.
So audio is limited.
Then there's flashing or
wiggling brief briefly but not
continuously.
If you flash or wiggle
constantly, some people will
get epileptic seizures and other
people will not look at
it because they assume
it's a ad.
So for example, this is
something you're going to see
more and more of in the future,
and you are starting
to see more and more of
it in various places.
Which is if you want to get
somebody's attention with an
error message you wiggle it.
That error message went one
pixel up, one pixel down, one
pick left, one pixel right,
and then stopped.
Stopping is very important.
That will attract your eye.
Why?
Because it might be a leopard.
Right?
Your eye does not know
what that is.
It just knows that there's
movement in the periphery.
So it yanks the fovea right
over there because
it might be a leopard.
So blinking is a poor
substitution for wiggling if
you can't wiggle.
But it's better than nothing.
But again the important
thing is to stop.
OK I'm going to talk about
cognition now.
I'm going to switch gears and
talk about cognition.
Short term versus long
term memory.
When I was in graduate school
cognitive psychologists
believed there were places in
the brain where they was short
term memory and there was other
places the brain where
there was long term memory.
And different brain structures
accounted for them.
And they had models of short
term memory and models of long
term memory.
That's not the view anymore, now
that people can actually
study the brain in
operation using
magnetic resonance imagery.
Now we know that short term
and long term memory are
actually just two
characteristics of the same
memory system operating.
And short term memory is now
much more closely tied and
interpreted as being tied to
perception and attention than
it was in my graduate
school days.
So short term memory is a
representation of your
conscious mind.
It's what you're attending
to right now.
So short term memory
is not a place.
It's not a place where things go
from perception and things
are hauled in from
long term memory.
It's not like an accumulator
in a computer.
That's not what short
term memory is.
Short term memory
is the stuff--
think of it this way.
Your memory system is
this huge warehouse.
And everything in there
is old and dusty and
covered with cobwebs.
And occasionally something
new is shoved
in through the doors.
And while it's being shoved
into the doors it's
illuminated because
the door is open.
And then the door slams shut
and the stuff comes in.
And it goes dark just like
everything else.
Except that there are four
searchlights in the ceiling.
And they can look at four
things at once.
Four, not seven.
How many remember the magical
number seven plus or minus two
from your school days.
That is now known to
be an overestimate.
The actual capacity of
short term memory--
and when I say capacity I
don't mean it's a place.
It's not a bucket.
But you have four searchlights
that can look at four things
at the same time.
Some people have five.
But most people it's four.
Four, plus or minus one.
For dogs it's one, plus
or minus one.
And so those four things that
those four searchlights can be
looking at at any time are
things like goals, numbers,
words, objects.
If a search light is pulled away
from what it was looking
at then the whole thing is lost
from short term memory.
So short term memory is again--
it's not a place.
It is what you're attending
to right now.
So that's why you can have the
situation of sitting in your
living room reading and then
hearing the cat meow.
And saying, oh I have
to feed the cat.
And getting up to go and
And then having the phone ring
and then having your brother
talk to you on the phone.
Then you finish talking to your
brother on the phone and
go sit down and go
back reading.
Then the cat meows again
and you go oh, I
forgot to feed the cat.
Because your brother's call
pulled one of the search
lights off your goal
of feeding the cat.
So here's a short term
memory test.
Memorize those numbers.
Say your phone number
backwards.
Go ahead.
You do it?
OK, what were the numbers?
Anyone know?
OK, memorize these numbers.
Now, if you notice something
about those numbers namely
that they are the first seven
digits of pi, it now is not
seven things to remember.
It's one thing to remember.
And your brain can do
it much more easily.
Memorize these numbers.
That's probably three bits.
It's like odd numbers starting
at, ending at.
Memorize those words.
What are they?
Not bad.
Memorize those words.
Same number of words.
Same number of words,
one chunk.
So if we go to this website
and we look at what it's
showing us, it's showing
us search results.
So somebody has done a
search and they're
looking at the results.
And here are the results
down here.
And the website is nice because
it's giving us a way
to fill in advanced search
options if we want to adjust
our search.
But there's something important
it's not showing us.
What is that?
What did we search for?
And of course I'm going to
defend the programmer now and
I'm going to say, well you only
put it in 10 seconds ago,
what's wrong with you?
Can't you remember something
for 10 seconds?
No, because I'm human.
I have four searchlights
in my brain.
Maybe some of you are lucky
and you have five.
But got a certain number
of searchlights.
And they were totally pulled
away from my search terms by
the search results.
Because all my attention is
focused there trying to figure
out, are those results
relevant to what
I was looking for?
Now long term memory is
that warehouse I was
talking about earlier.
And the memories in their--
memories are also tied to
perception in the current view
of cognitive psychologists.
Think of it this way.
If I look at his face, let's
say I look at Dan's face.
What happens in my visual system
is starting at the
visual cortex and moving forward
in my brain, millions
of neurons fire.
A huge pattern of
neurons fire.
And that pattern is my
recognition of Dan's face.
That's my memory
of Dan's face.
And if I look at Ben, a
different set of neurons fire.
It's very much similar because
he's human and he's human and
he's you know about the
same age I guess.
But they're not the same.
And so I'm not going to--
the thing is the human brain
can tell the difference
between this pattern of a
million neurons and that
pattern of a new million
neurons firing.
And if I run into him-- if I run
into Dan on the street in
San Francisco, another set
of neurons will fire.
And it will be very similar
because he's the same guy.
But it won't be the same because
we're in San Francisco
and not in this room.
And remember how we learned
earlier how context impacts
perception.
And so I might recognize Dan
on the street in Francisco.
And I might not.
Especially let's say if
he shaved his beard.
Or what if I run into Dan's twin
brother on the streets of
San Francisco.
And I say, whoa, hi Dan.
And his brother goes, what are
you some kind of pervert?
Get away from me.
Right?
So here's the important thing
is that a huge pattern of
neurons fires.
That is recognition.
That's what recognition is.
And so experiences trigger
patterns corresponding to
features in your brain.
Your brain is a feature
recognition machine.
That's what your brain is.
And so similar experiences
trigger the same pattern.
That's recognition.
Recall, in contrast to
recognition, is something
completely different.
Imagine what recall is.
Recall is a particular pattern
in your brain of millions of
neurons becoming activated in
the absence of the stimulus
that produce it in
the first place.
That's hard.
Your brain is actually not
designed for that.
It's designed for recognition.
Getting a particular pattern
of neurons to fire again,
evoking a memory in the absence
of the stimulus that
originally produced
it, is difficult.
That's why recognition is
easy and recall is hard.
And that's also why the fact
that these patterns are big
collections of features is why
long term memory is error
prone, impressionist, free
associative, and easily biased.
So for example, features
may get dropped from
a particular memory.
So you may have seen
a whale shark when
you're out on the trip.
And 20 years from now, you and
your brother argue about
whether you saw a whale
or a shark.
Because features got dropped
from that memory.
So here's a long term
memory test.
Was there a roll of tape
in the toolbox?
Good.
What was your last
phone number?
The one before you have now.
Anyone remember it?
You do?
Oh that's good.
Was this a Pollock painting
or a Dalmatian?
You'll never ever
see the Pollock
painting in this again.
So you shouldn't be
burdening long
term memory as a designer.
So for example here's an
instruction that a designer
gave to a user.
Which is kind of funny because
the designer knew that they
were asking the user to do
something that users can't do.
Change your pin to a number
that is easy to remember.
That's part one.
Part two.
A pin can be 6 to 10 digits and
cannot start with zero.
Your pin must be numeric.
They have just given
you instructions
that you cannot follow.
And they know it.
Because at the bottom it
says, remember please
write down your pin.
Put it on a yellow sticky
underneath your computer so
that any guy can come
in and steal it.
Having your brain keep track
of features, keeping those
searchlights trained on certain
objects in your in
your memory is work.
It actually takes calories.
And so your brain does it
as little as possible.
So your brain tracks only
features crucial to the task.
So that causes something called
change blindness.
So if I show you that this
picture and then I change it,
I want you to tell me if
there's any change.
What has changed?
What changed?
OK, let me change it in a
different way so that I remove
the pause in between.
OK.
So your brain is going to
focus on the people.
Because you're human, your brain
will focus on the people
and their food and the
beer probably.
And so people say things like,
well he had a mustache in the
first one and he didn't have a
mustache in the second one, or
something like that.
But no, it's things that are
irrelevant to what you're
interested in that you aren't
going to notice.
So I'm getting close
to the end.
I'm like two slides
from the end.
So as I said earlier,
recognition is easy.
Recall is hard.
We recognize things
extremely quickly.
It doesn't take you very long,
especially if you're out in
the wilderness, to notice
something like that.
Because otherwise you wouldn't
be passing your genes on.
I took this picture
by the way.
Talk about getting into
the vehicle quickly.
So Lucy walking around on the
African savanna 4 million
years ago had to be able to
recognize objects very quickly
otherwise we wouldn't be here.
It doesn't take you very
long to recognize
this face, these faces.
And even more tellingly, it
doesn't take you very long to
recognize that you don't
recognize these faces.
And what this shows is that when
I was in graduate school,
people thought of the
brain as a computer.
And they were trying to figure
out what are the algorithms
that the brain uses to
do face recognition.
And so they said back in
those days, it can't
be, is it this one?
No.
Is it this one?
Can't be that because
it's way too fast.
So they said, it has to be
something like, is it in this
half of the database or is it in
this half of the database?
It's in this half.
OK.
Take that and split
that in two.
Is it in this half or
that half of the
database, binary search.
No.
It's way too fast for that.
Face recognition is
way too fast.
So they came up with all these
algorithms back when I was in
graduate school about
how the face
recognition can be so fast.
And now we know why
it's so fast.
It's because the brain
does not search.
The brain is a content
addressable
holographic memory device.
It's a recognition machine.
Like I said, those big
patterns go off.
So it's basically face
recognition and also
recognition that you don't
recognize a face is almost
instantaneous.
It's not searching.
There is no search.
Similarly people can recognize
very sophisticated patterns
like for example, Kasparov
versus Karpov, 1986.
If you're a chess master
you'll recognize that.
If you're not, you won't.
Finally, I guess I'll talk
about performing learned
routines versus new behaviors.
Performing learned routines is
easy, like riding a bicycle
after months of practice,
driving to the same workplace
after many years, and using
a touch pad after a
few years of practice.
Now the reason that's easy
is it's automatic.
Cognitive psychologists make a
distinction between what are
called automatic processing
and controlled processing.
Automatic processing uses
lots of different
parts of your brain.
It doesn't use up short
term memory.
So it's not using up those
four searchlights.
It's what we computer scientists
would call compiled
mode or parallel processing.
There are many processors.
You can multitask automatic
things.
So one way I think of it is that
every part of the brain
is a brain.
And so things that are automatic
and running in
compiled mode essentially,
you can do many of
them at the same time.
That's why I can walk and chew
gum at the same time, or I can
be whistling a tune that I've
very familiar with.
But try to do that with
something new, following a new
cooking recipe, driving
somewhere you've never been,
writing with your non-dominant
hand, switching from Mac to
Windows PC or vice versa.
That's controlled.
That consumes short term
memory and attention.
It's what we computer scientists
would call
interpreted mode or
serial processing.
There's only one processor
there.
It's called the attention.
There's only one processor
and you cannot multitask.
So you can only do one novel
thing at a time.
You can multitask a novel
thing with an automatic
things, any number of them.
So let's just do a test.
Recite the alphabet A to
M. Go ahead recite the
alphabet A to M. Easy.
Recite backwards, M to A. That's
controlled, requires
short term memory, requires
attention.
Hum the first measure of
"Twinkle Twinkle Little Star."
Go ahead, do it.
Hum it backwards.
Control processing requires
short term memory, requires
attention, full attention.
So all of the things that
I showed you is why user
interface design is a skill not
something anyone can do by
following user interface
guidelines.
And that's why knowing the
cognitive basis helps us
prioritize and recognize
which rules to
follow in each situation.
Now I'll take any questions
that anyone has for
as long as you want.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF JOHNSON: Thanks.
Yes?
MALE SPEAKER: So this model of
short term and long term
memory that you were discussing,
how is this
consistent with the fact that
there's a phenomenon where
people go unconscious in
accidents or concussions lost
memory of the four or five
minutes preceding the
accident, people take Versed
and not lay down
the memory as well?
So that model seemed, or that
close result seemed to
[INAUDIBLE] the old model of
it being a different short
term memory [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah one of the
things that had been noticed
when I was in graduate school
was that people come back from
combat situations with certain
parts of their brain shot away
or auto accidents or whatever.
Some of them can remember
new things.
And others can't.
And another phenomenon like
the ones you described.
And so that's why they sort of
thought there had to do these
certain places where there was
short term memory and other
places where there was
long term memory.
And what they now know or now
believe is that there are
certain areas of the brain that
are essentially gateways.
They're sort of bottlenecks
for information.
And if those are shot away or
damaged, then the ability for
the brain to sort of generate
and compare these patterns
becomes destroyed.
So that's basically it.
It's now thought of as instead
of that short term memory
here, let's say in
the hippocampus.
Because that's where they used
to think it was when I was in
graduate school.
Is that the hippocampus
is somehow--
well remember I said earlier
that the human brain can
compare patterns and can
tell whether it's
seen a pattern before.
They don't know why that is, but
maybe it's possible that
the hippocampus is involved in
that, in that comparison.
So I guess what I'm saying is
that now the understanding of
short term memory versus long
term memory is not as cut and
dry as it was back in the '70s,
when they thought that
short term memory is in the
hippocampus and long term
memory is in the cerebral cortex
or something like that.
I don't know if that answers
your question.
MALE SPEAKER: Well it doesn't
explain those phenomena, but
maybe I have to look
deeper for that.
I understand that.
JEFF JOHNSON: So say exactly
what the phenomena was.
MALE SPEAKER: The phenomena
that somebody in the car
accident doesn't remember three
minutes before the car
accident, which normally would
have been laid down in short
term memory or long term,
whatever you want to call it.
JEFF JOHNSON: Right and so there
is some process by which
stuff comes in from perception
and gets put
into long term memory.
I mean one of the things that
we know now which is kind of
interesting.
If you're a musician, they know
now that it's better to
practice for 15 minutes and then
sleep than to practice
for eight hours.
Because the sleep has something
to do with the stuff
you practice getting
laid down.
So I don't know if I can answer
your question fully.
MALE SPEAKER: Peripheral
vision-- sometimes people talk
about athletes like pro
quarterbacks having great
peripheral vision.
Has that been tested
[INAUDIBLE]?
JEFF JOHNSON: Well I wouldn't
doubt it since there's all
sorts of genetic variation
and there's a lot of
randomness in our genes.
And so that's why for example
those people 4 million years
ago who could actually see the
leopard coming at them are the
ones who survived.
And those who didn't see
the leopard, maybe the
neanderthals, are not.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEFF JOHNSON: Not that I know
of but one thing that--
have ever heard of
the "Door" study?
Go to YouTube and type
in the "Door" study.
So that's a situation where
it's not really peripheral
vision, it's more has to do
with change blindness.
But basically if you get someone
in a situation where
you change out a person
in front of.
They're interacting with a
person and you change the
person out.
A lot of people don't notice.
But some people do.
And they don't know yet
whether there's any
systematic-ness to that or
whether it's just random.
MALE SPEAKER: I was wondering,
do you recommend--
should some user interfaces or
types of interactions rely
more on long term memory and
others have to be designed for
a situation where someone has
to keep track of something
right then?
How do we apply this
in that way?
JEFF JOHNSON: OK so it's
certainly the case that some
user interfaces are designed
to be walk up and use.
Or at least to be used in a
situation where it's been a
year since you walked up
and used it before.
And so you're not going
to remember details.
Like for example, recovering
files from a backup system,
how often are you going
to have to do that?
So that user interface is
probably going to have to be
designed differently from the
user interface for handling
your email, which you do
every morning for half
an hour or an hour.
So people who design walk up and
use interfaces really have
a different sort of mindset,
design mindset, than the
people who are designing user
interfaces that are going to
be used by which people
who have a lot of
experience and training.
I'm not sure that exactly gets
on your question which was--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I think
that ties into it.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah,
the thing is air
traffic control for example.
Intense information overload all
the time, and also extreme
danger if you screw up.
So that user interface has to
really support making sure
that you can see things.
So peripheral vision
for example.
If there are planes over here,
but you're looking over here,
they have to somehow
get your attention.
Actually a lot of people these
days are thinking about user
interfaces for security guards
at airports and places like
that, security checkpoints.
Because think about that job.
Nothing happens for months or
even years at a time and then
something happens.
And you have to be attentive.
But it's hard to be attentive
when you've been bored for
three years.
So how do you design a user
interface to make sure that
someone notices something is
happening now when nothing has
happened for the last
three years?
So there's a lot of attention
being paid to
that particular problem.
OK, thank you.